in 2015 psychology professor jonathan
hight and free speech activist greg
lukianov published the coddling of the
American mind in the Atlantic the
article argued that speech codes trigger
warnings and safe spaces on college
campuses were disastrous for education
and mental health it quickly became the
most read article in the history of the
magazine and now they've expanded it
into a new book with the same title
Lukie onif is a lawyer by training who
heads fire the foundation for individual
rights and education which fights for
free speech on campus Hite teaches at
New York University and is a co-founder
of let grow the free range parenting
advocacy organization and heterodox
Academy which promotes intellectual
diversity among faculty I sat down with
them to talk about why they believe that
good intentions and bad ideas about the
supposed for Jilla tea of young people
is setting up a generation for failure
Gregg Jon thanks for talking with our
patient early on in the book you posit
that what is new today is the premise
that students are fragile they explain
what you mean by that
well several years ago this is what led
me and John to write our original
article back in 2015 for the Atlantic
also called coddling the American mind
we started seeing a trend in which
students were sort of medicalizing the
excuses for why they were demanding
censorship and just the fact that
students were you know demanding new
speech codes demanding trigger warnings
demanding you know microaggression type
policies and this was different as
you're the head of the ire of free
speech group for higher ed you know and
on campuses it was new that students
were calling for this as opposed to it
being imposed on them I say this every
time but it bears repeating
I started at fire in 2001 for my entire
career the main centers on campus were
administrators
sometimes professors got into the act
the most tolerant the most free free
speech group on campus were the students
themselves and it seemed seemingly
overnight sometime around 2013-2014 we
saw this big discontinuity suddenly it
was the students themselves who are
asking for dis invitations new speech
codes all of these restrictions but what
was also strange about it was
increasingly they were making a sort of
medicalised argument that I need to be
protected from offensive speech because
it can
I mean some sort of medical way and
that's why John and I wrote the original
articles so students today define
themselves as fragile some of you do
unfortunately and I think you know I
there's also the argument sometimes that
it's rhetorical tactic and I think that
is sometimes true but when you see the
the big increase in anxiety and
depression I think there are the many
students who really do have a
self-fulfilling prophecy that
essentially that that's leading them to
greater anxiety and depression so the
book the first part is built around what
you guys called three untruths that are
kind of you know overarching background
hypotheses or assumptions that are
governing the way we deal with kids or
the way that younger people talk about
themselves the first one is the untruth
of fragility and the subtitle or the
slogan is what doesn't kill us makes us
weaker John what is the untruth of
Phrygia so my first book was called the
happiness hypothesis and and I I
surveyed ancient writings and I found
ten ancient ideas that have really stood
the test of time that have come down to
us and one of them of course is what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger you
can find versions of that in Chinese
literature and Western literature when
Gregg came to me in the summer 2014 and
said the strange stuff is happening on
campus and students are acting as though
you know as though if they're exposed to
some idea that they hate that it's not
just gonna make them angry it's gonna
actually harm them and this is the exact
opposite of course of ancient wisdom and
as we as we started working on this as
we started writing the article I
realized you know it's as though you
know it's as though on university
campuses people had read the happiness
hypothesis and then done exactly the
opposite like exactly the opposite of
what the ancients said you should do to
live a happy fulfilled effective life
and so when Gregg and I teamed up to
write the article it's just so clear we
can use cognitive behavioral therapy we
can use all sorts of techniques to say
well this is if you actually want to be
strong happy and effective here's how
you should do it it's the opposite so
that was what it was just very easy to
summarize that first grade on truth as
what doesn't kill you makes you weaker
you know my variation on whatever
whatever doesn't kill me always makes me
hungry
I know where that leads me the next on
truth is the untruth of emotional
reasoning and the catch phrase that you
used to describe that are short hand has
always trust your feelings right what's
wrong about that always trust your feel
is one of our great untruths and I think
it's the one that people some people
hear and they'll be like well that
sounds right that sounds from an NGO
with your gut go with your gut that
sounds badly I'm back to hunger but when
you'd stop a while to think about it or
you consult any ancient philosopher you
look at modern psychology it's terrible
advice
and I'm a big proponent of the cognitive
behavioral therapy and that's what the
original 2015 article was largely about
but I always ask people to kind of drop
the tea from it the therapy part of it
because really all cognitive behavioral
therapy is is learning to talk back to
the wild exaggerations in your own head
by being able to label them as
all-or-nothing thinking or
catastrophizing or over generalization
we have a whole list of common cognitive
distortions in the in the book and
amazingly if you teach yourself how to
do these you can actually experience
decreased anxiety decreased depression
was there a moment when we unlike did we
know them and forget them or is it just
that you know emotionalism became more
popular I think I think it's a recurrent
theme all throughout history well you
know whenever we see a new movement
coming in and it seems to be opposed to
something that we think is valuable it's
usually driven by the pursuit of
something else good as we've had more
diversity especially more diversity by
mental health status there's an effort
to be more sensitive to not not tell
people they're wrong not say things that
will upset people and so it's usually in
pursuit of a good but the idea that you
have your experience you have your
perspective and that's valid and nobody
should criticize you for that nobody
should challenge you and that seems like
a welcoming thing to do but just imagine
at freshman orientation they've got a
whole bunch of students coming and
imagine university presidents saying
welcome to college now you come here
with certain prejudices and beliefs and
feelings go with them don't question
them spend four years reinforcing them I
mean my god what a waste of time and
money yeah you mentioned early on you
say you know there are no clear villains
here right so which is helpful because
it is this is it's easy particularly in
a kind of partisan polarized America to
be like oh well this is all like leftist
or right as
whatever and their that's right so my
second book was called the righteous
mind and it was in the subtitle is you
know why good people are divided by
politics and religion and so the theme
of it is where we are designed by
evolution to do tribal warfare we're
really really good at forming
us-versus-them which will get us into
the third great untrue right on truth of
us against them life as a battle between
good and evil people right so that's
like that's our default state you know
you don't have to teach kids to do that
I mean if you just put them outside
they'll figure out how to make teams and
compete and if you bring people together
in a college and you start talking them
about life is zero-sum and the economy
is zero-sum and if someone gets
something that means they took it from
someone else there's all sorts of things
you can do to activate tribal thinking
and turn people against each other and
what we need to do in a college campus
is do everything we can to shut that
stuff down especially if we want to
create diversity I mean it's it's it's
the most foolish thing we could do put
all these resources into increasing
diversity international diversity gender
every kind of diverse you can think of
and then highlight distinctions and turn
people against each other I mean it's
it's a recipe for turning college into a
Viper pin so they're speaking of
colleges of I prepared and I want to
talk about where where did these
untruths come from or what are some of
the ideas driving them you bring up a
neo markku Zionism you're talking about
Herbert Marcuse a-- who was a that you
know hugely influential thinker
particularly in the 60s countering the
sixties counterculture what is Markku
zine ism and why is it problematic in it
you know especially as it plays out on
college campuses if you defend free
speech on college campuses Herbert
Marcuse comes up all the time because
he's kind of seen as the leading
philosopher of a anti-free speech left
he wrote a wrote something called
repressive tolerance in the mid-60s that
was talking about if we really want to
have a tolerant society we have to
actually go further than just allowing
free speech we have to actually go and
punish the people who are saying the
anti progressive things I and the idea
of repressive tolerance was that the
idea that you had a marketplace of ideas
and everybody got a fair hearing and you
would hash it out that itself was
repressive because it maintained the
status quo by
giving the illusion of disagreement or
debate well no because if so there are
many lenses you can look at society
through one of them is power and
privilege and that's a useful lens
sometimes but if you look at everything
through the lens of power and privilege
and you seen he was writing in the 60s
and even though the Democrats at the
time controlled the house the Senate the
Supreme Court and presidents everything
his view was that conservatives were the
dominant force in society they
controlled business in the military so
you can chew his credit also I mean
Democrats in the 60s
you still had of segregation by the time
he wrote but by the time he wrote
repressive tolerance that was after this
everybody yeah but the point is that if
you see if you if you have this
worldview much everywhere you look what
you see you don't see people walking
down the street you see oppressors and
victims oppressors and victims and then
you think about free speech and you say
well if we just have you know John
Stuart Mill type free speech the
powerful people the right are going to
dominate the white people dominate
dominate to people of color we can't
have that so true taught you know open
tolerance would actually lead to
oppression what we need is to repress
conservative thought and he almost says
it directly we need to touch it when
he's coming out of the Frankfurt School
you know where culture is a kind of
epiphenomena of economic power etc so
like you really do have to shut down the
culture in order to get at the root
causes of things and it seems to me you
know I I in reading your book one of the
things that had helped explain to me was
when I was in grad school in the late
80s and early 90s there were a bunch of
people literally I had professors I went
to SUNY Buffalo who had been at Berkeley
during the you know when Reagan was tear
gassing things and shutting the campus
down those people all loved the idea of
free speech the whole idea of the
university was you go there and you just
talk about the most batshit crazy ideas
and you just you talk it out the
generation that came in right after that
were they never mentioned more cuza but
they were clearly following that where
there was you know we we don't want an
open discussion we know what the right
answers are and the question is how do
you implement that and how do you
indoctrinate students to go out into the
world and you know act as advanced man
advancement
for these things that's right so I think
what that shows is is the increasing
incoherence when people are playing
different games so there's all kinds of
games that we can play and we have
evolved software for each one so one of
them is called the war game or the
victory game in which it's us versus
them and and we're gonna do whatever we
can to beat you and sometimes we might
have to fight dirty especially if the
stakes are high and then there's the
discover truth game and we can do it in
groups and that's the way you know Plato
Plato's dialogues were organized in that
way the people would argue but they were
there to have a good time to to to push
against each other knowing that that
would lead them to truth especially if
facilitated by a lot of wine so that's a
very different no so that no broads
allowed right so you could have a really
important conversation that's right so
that when we don't be distracted so but
then poets also could take a hike yeah
the point is that there's very different
games that one can do and if you know if
people in university are playing a
certain game and it's the it's the
pursue truth game and then you come in
you're arguing for free speech well
that's very consistent it's a variation
on the same game but if other people
come in and say no the point is
political victory we're here to fight
for these goals against that party and
everything we do from freshman
orientation through extracurricular
activities everything's organized for
victory totally incompatible games it's
like having tennis players and football
players on the same court like it just
doesn't work so you know one of the
things that you talk about in the book
are identity politics particularly the
way that they play out on college
campuses and identity politics you talk
about them being based on things like
race and gender rather than ideology or
class explain a little bit about that
because it's you know we have interest
groups right but our identity politics
kind of a subset of how we form affinity
groups or what's how does that factor
into all this one thing I feel like that
that's one of the big differences
between the book and they are the
article we wrote back in 2015 and I
explained it sometimes this way in 2015
we're arguing that you know what we're
teaching a generation the habits of
anxious and depressed people and there's
one shouldn't be surprised that they end
up being anxious and depressed in
one of the major things we added was
we're also teaching them the habits of
tri tri ballistic polarized people and
so but when we first decided that we're
gonna talk about a 10-6 from the book I
was to save at least a little nervous we
have a fire truck you know I come from a
very sort of non partisan grunt coming I
kept try to bring people together kind
of background but when I read John's
first draft of it it was all based on
very very clear well-established
psychologies studies that even people
who look alike can be very easily taught
to think of each other on separate teams
and now we're doing this with you know
both with our foot is powerfully on the
gas as possible and then wondering why
people feel so divided yeah so just to
follow up on that I think the key thing
that we do in the book I mean we're
wading into incredibly polarized
territory you know I mean there really
is a moral panic on the write about free
speech on campus so we get this weekend
people when you say a moral panic you
mean it's not true no that's the thing
so a moral panic means you have an
ecosystem in which the most outrageous
story is amped up pushed out people
devour it and they they have a kind of a
paranoid view so so right-wing media has
really geared up especially since the
protests in the campus protest in 2015
provide all those videos of students
screaming at professor shadow
obscenities at them so there really is a
moral panic on the right and then the
left can look at that say that's just a
moral panic that's all there is but to
say there's a moral panic doesn't mean
there isn't also a really serious
problem and we you know so surveys of
current students people are much more
wary of speaking their mind as one
students said to dead mashuk the the
director of bedrocks Academy one of her
students said silence is safer that's
her guiding rule silence is safer so
there is a real prop so my point is it's
an incredible main battle grounds of the
culture war and we could go in and say
Oh Marxism and sjw's and identity
politics but that's not that's not what
we're about what we're about is saying
let's just try to understand this there
are no villains here people are pursuing
moral ends so what we do both in the
social justice chapter which is chapter
3 I'm sorry the identity politics
chapter we cover three and in Chapter 11
we cover social justice as we say
there's something good and right here
that students are pursuing and if
they're if they're
trying to get equal rights and access
for people who are excluded or feel
marginalized based on identity
categories
that's a justice issue and of course we
should all support that there's nothing
wrong with organizing your politics
based on car ownership or eating habits
or race those are all perfect legit the
dividing line is between those who try
to organize it saying we are all human
we're all in this together and some of
us are being denied their rights and
that's what Martin Luther King did
that's what a lot of the great civil
rights leaders did and that ultimately
wins that actually attracts people it
lowers their defenses and you can show
them that actually there's injustice
being done so that works and you still
find that especially in religious
organizations on campus they tend to do
that but the other way is to say let's
all unite let's all come together
against them one of the things where you
talk about where these untruths come
from and you were getting at this one of
the things you say is that there's a
really intense political polarization
and sorting process that has to do with
things like negative partisanship
explain how what that is and then how
that feeds into these kinds of the
inability of us to to kind of see
ourselves as common on campuses
political polarization is definitely one
of the common interest between me and
John that I'm very exercised about you
know if there was a great book by Bill
Bishop called the big sort that talks
about how people increasingly live in in
counties that are more politically
partisan and as people have followed
that research even deeper it turns out
it's even were divided into city blocks
that are more politically partisan and
then add that the fact that we have
social media that actually encourage you
to surround yourself by an echo chamber
they give you sort of a little dopamine
rush by doing it or we've set up a
situation all do two things that I
otherwise think of as positive that's
why we call them problems of progress in
the book that are absolutely set to make
us more polarize and so this was a
predictable sort of outcome that we saw
getting worse you know even even 10
years ago but polarization is sort of
part of the secret sauce that makes us
so much more intense although you know
it's against the political science
Morris Fiorina at Stanford talks about
how the polarization is typically
oversold by the media or the people
talking about it are not representative
of most people and so when you look at a
lot
of major issues you know whether it's
abortion whether it's immigration
whether it's pot legalization there are
broad 60 70 80 there's a lot of ways of
polarization and if you're focusing on
people's attitudes about issues then I
think theory is right that you don't see
like a giant bimodal distribution most
people still know middle we're not
concerned with issues we're concerned
with how much people hate the other Sox
if you look at effective partisan
polarization that has gone steadily up
and it's continued to go up I think it's
even sharp I'm not sure in the last two
years that's what matters so if you're
creating a diverse community so let's
suppose you have black and white on
campus together and then you do
something that increases the degree to
which black and white people hate each
other is that going to help or hurt your
mission on campus similarly if you have
left and right students you do have left
right students in every campus and if
you had used to have some some
right-leaning professors now there's
hardly any but if you had if the camp is
generally leaned left and left and right
didn't hate each other a lot they just
kind of disliked each other that was the
status quo for a long time and that is
kind of work and is that I mean it's
that golden ageism to look back I mean I
think we can all look back 20 years or
30 years or whenever we're in college or
grad school and be like well you know it
wasn't perfect but it's better than it
is now is it I mean here you're saying
it is objectively worse William William
F Buckley wrote was a God in man at Yale
so the the the concerns of conservatives
that there's a left-leaning professorial
those have gone on for a long time but
but compared to what happens to
political dissenters now it's a lot
rougher now and then social media has
changed that one of the things that
changed it is that they're used at least
be the ratio across the whole profesor
it used to be just two to one throughout
much of the twentieth late twentieth
centuries two to one to two one left
right okay and that's self descriptions
yeah whether use more or less whether
you yeah whether you whether the sir
they're a few surveys that have looked
at this and whether you say are you on
the left or the right or whether you say
Democrat Republican the results are very
similar but in the 90s is when things
change and when and now there's a lot of
reasons for that it's the baby boom
coming into the professorial that's also
the Republican Party changes the party
of Newt Gingrich change isn't that
gonna turn off a lot more yeah you might
talk a little bit about Newt Gingrich is
kind of one of the ghosts of this book
in a very negative way how does how does
Newt Gingrich kind of here's what guys
we produce s all around me I know that's
really do you say there are no villains
if there was a villain Gingrich would be
one but and by some professor he's a PhD
or yeah yeah well a little bit of no I
shouldn't I should say no that's not
true but so yes Gingrich is a villain in
that he instituted changes in Congress
that greatly ramped up political
polarization now again people do things
for good reasons and the Democrats
treated the Republicans terribly for
decades and so when his Republicans took
over in 95 he wasn't gonna say okay all
is forgiven let's be nutso you know I
understand why he did it he's not a
moral villain he just is a causal
villain now these things will end it's
also a react but I mean all of this
stuff is interrelated but it was less of
when Bill Clinton took over I can
remember I was in grad school and people
were so triumphant that he was the first
baby boomer president and he was one of
us you know and I had an office mate who
said like you know we won neck and I was
like I you know I voted for I I don't
even remember what it was and I would
say political but he was like we won and
it is never going back you have lost and
I was like okay and then within six
months Clinton was such a disaster early
on and that like people just stop
talking about politics and it was
actually kind of a good day
but Gingrich was yeah these guys are
like dark twins they were they were very
polar well that's right but that brings
us to another another factor going on
here's the change of the generations
yeah and so there is there is some
really interesting evidence we covered
in Chapter eleven that however the
political world looks to between
fourteen and twenty-one or so is kind of
a sensitive period that tends to sort of
set you're not in stone but that tends
to have a lasting effect for the rest of
your life and so the greatest generation
as it's called they came together to
fight fascism when they then went on to
run the country they did a great job of
it at least they were I should say they
were able to work together they had much
more of a spirit of putting the country
first whereas the baby generation again
gross generalizations was lots of
generation but if you're you know if
1968 if 1968 is in your sensitive period
and then you come into government 20
years later you're gonna have a view of
the left and right which is more likely
to say if you're on the left we've got
to smash these you know these racist
bastards or if you're on the right we
got to smash these anti-american
whatever so the change of generations is
a big part of the story as well so what
happens now though because the boomers
are you know they're in their dotage I
mean is the next generation is is it
clear the next generation of profess
aureate because that those aren't 14 to
21 year olds I mean they're not the kids
that you're talking about who who are
failing
yeah well the I wanted to respond a
little bit to the golden ageism yeah you
know you know but probably brought up I
would still I think both of us would
still choose to live in 2018 if we were
actually asked to live in any year 90s
but but that's why we talk about you
know problems of progress these are the
kind of things that you can see getting
worse because because all the other
things are getting better and if but if
you look at the data on you know voting
patterns for example in the u.s. it's
very clear that we that we did have a
long period of sort of centrism it and
it pops up on everything that you see
when one of the things that you talked
about our rises in anxiety depression
and other mood disorders where is that
coming from among kids because that they
go to college and then they're not quite
you know they're fragile they're not
quite as resilient is that a real thing
or is it a function of overdiagnosis or
a mix or you know what wait is there
something in the water now we looked
into that very carefully so when we were
writing our article in 2014 and 2015 I
was responsible for finding the stats is
this really happening and I couldn't do
it it was a bunch of anecdotes it was a
few weak correlational studies because
in 2014 all we had was data from
2012-2013
but despite the gigantic rise in anxiety
and depression began around 2012-2013 in
college it's basically kids born after
1995 especially what are sometimes
called Gen Z or I Gen they were raised
differently they have much higher rates
of anxiety and depression you might
think it's just that they're comfortable
talking about it so it could just be an
artifact but we look into this very
carefully suicide rates tracked the same
trends as self-report and hospital
admissions for slitting your wrists or
otherwise cutting your body and and all
the signals are consistent in saying
it's especially girls boys are up in all
these too the girls are well and and you
talk about how social media plays a role
here and neither of you are I don't want
to say alarmist that may actually you
may be an alarmist but you're not in
Sarnia social is is is a bad thing but
rather that if you're coming to social
media what that is what's forming your
kind of early experiences versus if you
come to it after you work actually let's
start with play because I think we need
to set this up so what our kids bring
when they reach adolescence and then how
does social media change them in
adolescence so I think we really need to
start with play so I mean the way to
think about this is suppose we just
decided that you know reading is
dangerous you know kids could come
across all kinds of bad stuff and so
let's not let them really you know every
early novel was about how it's a really
bad idea to read novel okay then go out
and ruin your life but all right so
suppose we said no kid can read until
he's 14 unless he has an adult sitting
right there supervising him so they
still learn to read but they're always
watched they're they're very restricted
and then at 14 then they can read what
they want do we think that this might
have a lasting effect probably it would
they wouldn't love reading as much they
wouldn't have learned as much and in in
a way we've sort of done that with play
because kids play all mammals play this
is how we wire up our nervous systems
but we started deciding in the nineties
and you wrote that wonderful article I
thank you for sending it to me putting
your finger on this in 1997 we're
becoming totally overprotective in the
90s we're not we were child proofing the
world that's right there's a name of the
article so Google child proofing the
world so if we if we don't let kids play
unsupervised until they're 14 or so and
then we say okay now you can go out with
your friends in play but you know at 12
you can't go out because you might be
kidnapped and do we think this might
have a lasting effect do we think this
might delay maturation what so what what
is your take on why why did childhood go
from being relatively unstructured to
being hyper scheduled so I'm in part you
know what what are the causes of that I
think we're seeing the effects of any
chance that kids can't
kind of deal with things but what what
what created this new world of hyper
schedule of childhood good intentions so
it's a few things it's the combination
of cable TV which and a couple of
high-profile killings in the in this
well Etan Patz in 79 and then Adam Walsh
in 81
but even though child killings and
abductions didn't go up our awareness of
them did and so this is the Michael
Moore thesis and Bolin for columnas we
start getting scared out of our minds in
the 80s cable TV does this to us but
we're not we're we're not really
cracking down until the 90s ironically
that's right when the crime wave ends in
the 90s so it's the it's fear especially
fear of abduction
it's the increasing competition to get
into college so now we're being we have
this idea that you you got to start
listening to Mozart oh my god then baby
is fine I don't know if you guys use
these on your kids we bought one of them
and it just you know it's basically I
don't it's hard to put it this way but
it's sort of like you know training for
no I shouldn't say never
first particular mental illness I should
say it's not it's not human it's not
anyway yeah so but there's a perception
that you have to start your kid you know
at age one or month ones in order to get
into the schools to get to where they're
gonna be when they're 18 there were a
couple of really dramatic things that I
learned from from working on this book
with John and one of the strong one of
them one of the most surprising one was
how well established it is that younger
people need unstructured time to play
and if I look at sort of like my my you
know my friends who went to law school
with and the way they raised their kids
you would think that this was something
that no psychologist actually knew or
there's no research supporting it and
finding out that it's overwhelmingly
supported and but nonetheless every
parent I know thinks they have to have
their kids scheduled from 6 a.m. to till
bedtime is actually difference also
though and again this get this can be
taken in the wrong way but how much of
it is also the rise of two-parent career
to career households so that you don't
have you know kids need to be supervised
or there's a sense of you're not going
to leave a five-year-old at home while
you're both out
King so you putting them in your
institutional that's that's kind of
tricky it's not so much that now that
women are working we have to put them in
things it's not that because in fact
even though women are working vastly
more than they did in the 50s and 60s
they're also spending more time with
their kids they did in the 50s and 60s
and men are spending more time so it's
it's changes in your parenting problem
that Lord you know we're spending too
much time with her exactly that's right
overprotective we were protecting them
yeah so but the job of a parent as is
often said is to work him or herself out
of a job mm-hmm and we're not doing that
we're basically working we're basically
arranging things that we get to we have
to keep parenting it's it's fine then
there's also you talked about that I
mean the the increase in things like
homework I mean I mean it's not just
parent you you talk about paranoid
parenting which I think most parents
would agree with that you know and of
course they're paranoid but you know
they're paranoid for good reason right
when it comes to protecting my kid but
it's also things like homework yeah
there's more homework than there used to
be and there's the word is actually the
medium there's no correlation between
homework and academic outcomes or
anything like that but it but that's how
you know you're sending your kid to a
good school is if they're crying every
night because they have eight hours of
homework yeah well that's right so if we
really cared about our kids happiness we
would do what is most conducive to
mental health autonomy and resilience
and that is give them a lot of
unsupervised time a lot of unsupervised
playtime with other kids and ideally
outdoors part of this is the work from
Peter gray one of he's a Boston College
one of your cofounders of light Grove
let's talk a little bit about what grow
sure sure so I guess we should bring in
Lenore skin az yeah the world's worst
mom world's mom who let her son her son
was begging to ride the subway and at
the age of nine you know I think was
2009 and she finally said okay you can
do it and she got him all set up and he
rode he even had to do an exchange and
got home and he was thrilled he was so
excited and then she talked about this
in public in a newspaper column and some
people got very upset it's irresponsible
and so it became a big flashpoint around
then for for norms about parenting but
it's really important to realize the
norms about parenting had changed
between the 80s let's say when you were
it was good Cleary kids out
and by 2010 if you had your kids outside
and you didn't know you couldn't see
them you could have your kids taken away
from you yeah not everywhere but but it
was becoming more prized for reason
writes regularly about stories of you
know parents who let their kids play in
their front yard and then it's not right
yard front yard happens occasional
that's it's it's if they step off the
property so if they go play with other
friends if they go to a park across the
street then you can be arrested and and
if you think about it like what the kid
mostly needs is to learn how to be a
self-governing independent creature kids
need to learn how to live with liberty
and we're basically saying is no you
cannot start learning until you're 18
we're gonna keep you in a cocoon send
you up to college and then you're going
to be independent although we're gonna
send you up to a helicopter college
which will wrap you in all kinds of
protection and I just want to add that's
one of the things that I always have to
explain is the connection of sort of
locus of control the idea of how do you
avoid having anxious and depressed kids
and if you if you look at people who
feel like they have no control over
their own life of course they feel
depressed and anxious and so sometimes
when people will bring up like that
we're bashing like a generation we're
like first of all we're talking about
the parents and the structures around
around these students and I actually
feel terrible first a lot of these kids
because one the ones who are going to
the fancy schools grow up in a pressure
cooker where they're sort of pointed
like a rocket towards the towards these
top schools but never given a sense of
they can handle their life on their own
which is of course a formula for
depression anxiety all these troubles
that we see people are having fewer kids
people are also having kids when they're
older and is our older parents do they
tend to be more paranoid for X Y or z
reason but I think the decline of family
size is very important this is happening
all over the world and you know if you
have five kids and the other neighbors
all have four or five kids a there are a
lot of kids around and B if one of you
god forbid something bad happens you're
not left childless so this is what we
call problems of prosperity as we get
wealthier we have fewer children we
invest more in each and we are you know
obviously as you see in China with you
know four grandparents on one show you
know all the hopes right in that child
and so what's happening is as a social
psychologist I would say yeah we want
our kids to be happy but
we also want us to be prestigious we
want prestige and if those two conflicts
we might actually go with our prestige
and we want our kid to bring us prestige
and the fewer kids you have so this is
this is not across all the social
classes but middle class and above
there's an incredible focus on getting
into college and so if you combine
really bad psychology which is don't let
your kids waste their time playing that
doesn't get them into college yeah
that's right we're gonna cram them with
all kinds of supervised activities so
what you're doing is you're taking away
the thing they need most and giving them
things that won't make any difference
and then you know it actually doesn't
bring well it actually does bring you
prestige if you get them into it in
elite college but then they're depressed
and not very effectively well let's talk
a little bit about what is to be done
what are the obvious redress factors I
think the first thing that John can
speak to the best is a free range
parenting I mean that that's depth one
essentially yeah yeah we have to do is
we have to break it into three buckets
and so one of the themes of our book is
that this is a really complicated and
interesting sociological problem we say
that there are six different causal
threads we have six chapters and six
different causal threads that all came
together to to change the culture on
many campuses so we have to divide it
into what's happened to kids before they
get to college what are we doing at
college that brings out the worst in
some kids and what's happened in the
larger national political and media
ecosystem which includes social media so
it's three different buckets so I'll do
the kids you do the college Ranger so
the kids as great said the most
important thing is the free range
parenting and so this is why so Lenore's
can Daisy was she wrote this wonderful
book free range kids and Daniel Shipman
who's the chair of the board of fire
came to me to say you know we're sort of
losing the battle for hearts and minds
on free speech in college we need to
actually be working at younger ages and
I said well we need to get Lenore to be
you to wrap up her operation she needs
to really you know have an organization
and so Lenore agreed to do it I mean she
you know she doesn't like to organize
things but but she's very passionate at
her cause and so we said well we'll get
an executive director and so Tracy
Tomaso is the executive director of let
grow so if you go to let Grove org it's
a wonderful site we have all kinds of
suggestions because it's really hard to
do this on your own that's the thing
like ah I've been so you know once I
read Lenore's we're
a few years ago I'm trying to be more
free-range but it's really hard to do it
alone though I can send my kids out to
the park but there aren't any other kids
there who are unsupervised she can't
invite kids can't find a group so Lenore
has all kinds of ideas for how do you
create a play club how do you get kids
to meet up in a park how do you give
them more time in space to play at
school so a significant portion is kind
of really operationalizing the the
insights of people like Peter gray and
the sensibility of lenore to have a less
kind of scheduled childhood that's right
kids have to have huge amounts of
unsupervised time where they're
responsible with themselves where they
might get lost and that's if they've an
iphone they can they should be able to
navigate themselves home but the kids
have to have a lot more unsupervised
time younger kids have to have a lot
more play time and we ought to back off
on their conflicts now bullying is a
complicated thing we obviously don't
want bullying that happens repeatedly
over days with ZOA but but it's
complicated we don't want to be
intervening in their conflicts so much
and before we go on to the the college
part of this how do you as a
psychologist how do you figure out like
you know there was bullying in the past
and by all indications it was worse I
mean it's actually even less bad but we
take it more seriously but how do you
how do you make sure that you're not
just kind of creating a Hobbesian
nightmare and you're just like just
shake it off because that's also problem
well yeah so there's a difference
between a Hobbesian nightmare and and a
place that is is not like lala land so
the you know I think the best argument
we can give is what happened with
peanuts and peanut allergies so the
immune system is anti fragile it
requires exposure to dirt and germs it
has to learn what's friend and what's
foe but because some kids had peanut
allergies very few but it happened we
started saying we got to protect kids
from peanuts in the 90s and then as and
then the rate started going up so we had
to protect me even more and the rates
went up further and only in the last few
years has the evidence come in from a
controlled experiment a large controlled
experiment the leap study learning early
about peanuts showed conclusively that
was that fed up I like the cashew and
they divided they took kids were at risk
of allergy of allergies and other
allergies half the
they expose them to peanut dust from on
a puffed right a puffed corn snack that
has peanut dust on it so if you give
these at-risk kids peanuts
their rates of peanut have to go way
down and so in the same way if you let
kids out on the playground but you make
it incredibly safe so there's no risk
they actually don't learn as much as if
there are for example tree stumps Lenoir
points out how there's like guidance
tree stumps rocks everything must be
cleared because it presents a tripping
hazard really kids can't run through the
woods and learn to step over rocks and
so you know on the playground yeah we
don't want the kind of bullying that
destroys a kid's confidence that makes
them not want to go to school and that
the point is that it goes over multiple
days that we have to do something about
but we are so in reacting to real
bullying we now jump in whenever kids
have conflicts that's a really bad idea
you know one of the things the three of
us are you know of the same
socioeconomic class you know background
we're all white is there you know does
this make sense
mrl male does this is this you know just
we're like we're trying to preserve a
vestige of a world in which you know we
didn't have to work that hard and things
kind of went our way because do do women
do minorities experience things in that
same way yeah so if you look at
everything through the lens of privilege
and power it's obvious that we're doing
this not because we care about these
issues
Brenda devoted the last 10 to 20 years
to working for free speech and ancient
wisdom and political depo
not because of that but because we want
to preserve our privilege you might
think that but I think even if that was
true even if our motivation was entirely
selfish it's still true that everyone is
anti fragile with your black white male
or female if you are over protected you
will come out more fragile if you are
encouraged to just believe your feelings
you will come out less critical critical
thinker so the great truths and the
great untruths are equally true
regardless of race or gender so and
maybe now as you point out in the book
the rates particularly for for girls the
social outcomes Nexus whatever we're
doing is having a much bigger impact on
which is also kind of I mean paradoxical
because on another level women are doing
better than ever in terms of earning pay
and salary and and having more
opportunities talk a bit about in in the
college contours and also throw in talk
about the cognitive behavioral element
to this because that's I mean there's a
the part of the book which is almost I I
wouldn't say it's self-help but the
stuff about the cognitive behavioral
therapy conversations it seems really
different and new well I definitely have
friends who prefer for whom self-help is
a bad word and for me I've always wanted
to write a book that that talks about
freedom of speech as self-help
effectively and stoic philosophy for
example but when it comes to how we can
reform colleges how what we can do
better at colleges it's funny that I run
into people who kind of like throw up
their hands like they're just lost
causes you know there's nothing we can
do and of course to me and John were
like we've their own to notice this
particular problem around 2030 to 2040
it started in one academic year we this
is new and we haven't even done basic
things to make it better
now one and this sometimes surprises
people that we say this but we've got to
take the psychological issues going on
campus more not less seriously
University of cycle house psychologist
services are kind of overwhelmed but
there are other resources sometimes even
in apps that that you can give to
students who are in trouble and I'm like
big booster of CBT because I've
personally benefited from it it has
great research backing it up and what's
great about it too is it is also
something you can practice on a Dale on
a daily basis sorry they even make apps
that allow you to allow you to do that
so one we have to take actually the
psychological issues on campus more
seriously than we currently are but when
it comes to issues like freedom speech
academic freedom when people throw up
their hands that there's nothing to be
done about what's going on campuses most
colleges don't even have orientations
that seriously address the sophisticated
concepts of the undergird freedom of
speech inquiry
academic freedom and if you haven't even
done that step yet you can't really
blame students for not knowing a lot
about it which actually naturally brings
me to John and heterodox academies
wonderful in my program but also the
graphic oh yes yes that heterodox
Academy briefly what is it
function yeah so heterodox Academy is
something that I started with Nick
Rosencrantz a law professor and Chris
Martin a grad student sociology when we
had each all of us we'd each written
papers about how declining political
diversity in our fields is is damaging
our research and our the education we
give our students and so we thought hey
we should actually you know get together
here and keep attention on this issue
Nick is on the right Chris is on the
left I'm a centrist who votes Democrat
so this was not a partisan issue this
was a people care about their research
in their fields and and so we put up
this site and it was really just to
encourage faculty to think about the
need for viewpoint diversity and
challenge and and to defeat orthodoxy in
every field and it went live on
September 10th or so 2015 coincidentally
a month after our article came out and a
week or two before to purchase it
Missouri and then Claremont McKenna and
Yale and Amherst and Brown and
everywhere else so just before
everything blew up so 2015 is really the
pivotal year for a lot of stuff so we
were really formed just to promote
viewpoint diversity among researchers
but it turns out it's a big issue for
students too and so as we went on in
this and seeing the way students are
very passionate politically and the way
this somehow times can suppress open
discussion on campus people are afraid
to air dissenting views even those on
the Left are afraid to air dissenting
views so I thought you know we need to
put some good ideas out there we need to
expose be as Greg was saying we're not
teaching people about the value of your
point diversity or freedom of speech and
so John Stuart Mill's on Liberty one of
the greatest books in the Western
tradition chapter to it so it's five
chapters in chapter two is this gem on
free speech but it's kind of long and
it's got a lot of obscure stuff so
Richard Reeves who wrote a biography
John Stuart Mill he and I edited it down
just chapter two edited down to half its
length so seven hundred seven thousand
word essay and then it's beautifully
illustrated by Dave Ciccarelli who
really captures the metaphors about like
the power of shame and this is not a
book about censorship by government it's
a book mill was writing about social
censorship so we make this book free if
you go to heterodox academy org slash
mill you can download the PDF for free a
Kindle is three dollars and then the art
book is expensive to print so this is 20
dollars but our hope is that every high
school senior
and where every entering freshmen will
read it doesn't take long to read will
read and understand these amazing
arguments from 1859 that are just as
relevant today Amir Lawrence because in
the book in the coddling of the American
mind you pay special attention to the
University of Chicago yeah president's
recent kind of Restatement of of an Open
University what what was he proposing
and why is that yeah a good reform fired
you know we have a whole bunch of things
that we'd like universities to do almost
as first steps to start addressing
problems with conformity and free speech
but also incidental not incidentally the
the mental problems we're seeing on
campus one thing that any campus can do
that really shows that it's serious
about viewpoint diversity really serious
about debates across lines of difference
is a past of something like the Chicago
statement at this point nearly I think
of about 40 colleges across the country
a little fewer than that have passed
some version of the Chicago statement
that was originally written of course at
University of Chicago updating academic
freedom norms for the for the age of
trigger warnings and dis invitations
it's it's it's absolutely fabulous the
other thing that universities of course
could do is is get rid of their speech
codes there's been seventy plus lawsuits
over the years against campus speech
codes amazingly there's still about
thirty percent of them have what we call
red-light speech codes fire which just
mean really laughably bad ones and
universities even just out of their own
self-interest should be should be
getting rid of these speech codes and
one thing we have been seeing that it's
a little that is actually a sort of a
little glimmer of hope is that we're
seeing a lot more university presidents
a lot more professors taking the problem
of free speech on campus more seriously
now as you're seeing in some cases some
of their friends getting in trouble and
actually experiencing the the reality of
being afraid of having a single verbal
misstep on Twitter or in class as a you
know as a I was going to say practicing
academic I mean as a university
professor do you feel that the kind of
academic freedom understood as your your
ability to research whatever you want is
that growing as a trinken or is that a
different issue well there's two
separate issues one is my academic
freedom to study what I want
and why you would never restrict me in
any way doing that and I'm at the
business school and I've tremendous
freedom study whatever I want I've had
the full support of the two Dean's that
I've had so in terms of my freedom to
study what I want it's perfect but now
I'm at a stage in my career when it's
I'm finding that moral psychology can
help us understand why so many
institutions are malfunctioning our
politics our universities and now it's
spread these norms are spreading into
corporations so a business school gives
me a great great place to be to actually
apply these ideas that's been really fun
but the other piece of it is not that so
much the academic freedom of the
professor it's what happens in the
classroom that I think has changed for
me and for a lot of professors when our
article came at 2015 a lot of professors
were saying oh come on that's you're
just you know there's like ten anecdotes
at 10 different schools now when you
what I around you talk to professor's in
private most of them either have a story
of their own class where they said
something perfectly innocent and it blew
up and they were being called in front
of committees and it or it happened to a
friend I mean now everybody knows
there's a there's a problems not
necessarily at that most schools most
schools are not selective there are two
a year there's all sorts of reasons but
at the elite schools this is now very
very common and this is leading to a lot
of distrust students don't trust it
professors because they're looking for
microaggressions professors don't trust
their students because they can be
turned in for microaggressions in every
bathroom at NYU is a sign getting three
ways to report me if I say something
that someone thinks is biased
therefore I no longer take risks I know
and it's gotten even worse probably the
most recent trend that we've seen is
actually right-wing mobs coming after
professors too so we talked a lot about
in the book about people getting in
trouble you know even even just
tremendous internet scorn for an article
they were there they wrote which might
in some cases actually be protracted in
the face of contempt you know coming off
of social media so there was already a
pretty bad situation when it was just
internal to the university add to that
the fact that we now have this let's go
after this professor let's get this mr.
Follin and you pointed I I believe it's
turning-point USA kind of Trump loving
right-wing group that has created
professor watch live which you know I I
have to say I mean the the quality of
their work
is laughable on a certain level I kind
of like the idea of being able to know
more about professors but this is really
kind of McCarthyism or or you talk about
the witch hunts and the Cultural
Revolution under Mao this is like really
[ __ ] up
yeah well it's definitely the you know
the right wing sort of outrage machine
it can lead to you know things that
professors actually say in some cases
that they're they're used to being in
their bubble where it's just kind of
accepted now it's colliding with sort of
like the the right wing outrageous
sphere and it's and the results I had a
couple of professors who were on an
earlier version of this put up by David
Horowitz the you know ramparts left wing
editor then who became a super right
winger in the 90s and 2000's and it was
you know it was both a badge of honor
but also chilling yeah and and you know
it doesn't seem it's not a good way to
have a serious University academic
that's right so some people get into the
mindset of playing the war game let's
attack attack attack and that tends to
just make people get defensive I don't
think we're going to improve
universities by attacking them we think
that universities have tremendous moral
and intellectual resources
I guess Bill Clinton said famous for
saying there's nothing wrong with
America that can't be fixed by what's
right with America and I say the same
thing about universities there's nothing
wrong with universities that can't be
fixed by what's right with them we have
incredible research on how do you do
diversity on how do you foster a good
learning environment
we've research on leadership so we have
all kinds of ideas in the book for what
universes can do to draw on research to
not give in to political pressures
they're being pressured in the political
game to implement this that the other
training program which generally either
doesn't work or will backfire but if we
had a more empirically based program to
create a good learning environment two
very simple things one is the incredible
importance of good clear leadership
early on this was the theme at the
heterodox Academy conference where we
had president Zimmer of Chicago but many
of the administrators said it if you
don't set the norms clearly upfront that
this is a place where yes we respect
everybody we care about diversity
inclusion we will we will
you know we're concerned about anybody
who's being asked Lou
but that includes we allow people to
speak and if you shout down someone if
you stop someone from speaking or
listening that is such a violation of
our core values that you will be
expelled if you just say something like
that up front then you were not gonna
have problems
so leadership is absolutely crucial we
talk about that and then another I think
one of our simplest recommendations
which is I hope will provoke a lot of
discussion is we don't think eighteen
year olds should be on campus that is
there's been a very steady increase in
when people reach levels of maturity
this goes back to the 80s and 90s it's
been going up and up and up and that's
sort of a normal part of becoming a
wealthier society is childhood you know
there used to be no adolescence you know
it's so adolescence is lengthening
lengthening and as the book ijen shows
Jane Twain II says in many measures
eight-year-olds today are like 15 year
olds several decades ago they eighteen
year olds today are less likely to have
gone out drinking to have had a
boyfriend or girlfriend to have had a
job they've been home a lot on their
devices they are not at the same place
maturity wise so are you proposing that
we push College back yes a year or two
of some sort of activity away from the
home before you go to school be so pay
for every crag of the libertarian in
this dynamic to I please I make it clear
if I make that national version of this
which is essentially I mean you know I
wasn't going to start working when I was
11 I think that definitely there are 18
year olds are absolutely mature enough
to be good to be on campus I do however
think that if if we normalize gap years
if we normalize the idea of taking of
working for a year particularly like in
different parts of the country different
parts of the world it would lead to
lessen the problems we see today and at
fire I see this coming partially from
the fact that the constituency that so
often gets in trouble on campus are the
not the clone quote non-traditional age
students the ones who served in the
military or went back to school in their
30s but they're they end up getting in
trouble for what I consider to be kind
of good reasons because they're not as
easily told what to do they're not that
they have to have a sense of they have a
locus of control they have a sense of
maturity that someone is oftentimes it's
a good habit younger age so I think that
having sort of normalizing the gap year
which would create
would be a very good just to defend
myself I wasn't saying I'm not saying to
a liberator organization maybe the
federal law ie League schools if the
most prestigious schools if University
Chicago started saying we will give
preference to people who have taken a
year or two off that's well it would say
I'd be awesome yeah and then they would
find that their students are much more
ready to learn much more ready to
encounter diversity of views and it was
absolutely true when I went to law
school the ones who actually took some
time off you know the ones who just came
out of school what were the people who
are like oh so much work you know I'm
worried about a test yeah oh yeah I had
a similar experience working a couple
years before going to grad school grad
school was a kind of a vacation well
totally I was you know one of my best
friends was a guy was a carpenter for
ten years before law school and both of
us were like so you're you're frightened
of the fact that we have to read a lot
well we will leave it there we've been
talking with Greg Luciano Finn Jonathan
hight the new book is the coddling of
the American mind have good intentions
and bad ideas are setting up a
generation for failure thank you so much
now
[Music]